to win the first match,
but the writing was on the wall.
I eventually lost to the machine
but I didn't suffer the fate of John Henry
who won but died with his hammer in his hand.
[John Henry Died with a Hammer in His Hand Palmer C. Hayden]
[The Museum of African American Art, Los Angeles]
It turned out that the world of chess
still wanted to have a human chess champion.
And even today,
when a free chess app on the latest mobile phone
is stronger than Deep Blue,
people are still playing chess,
even more than ever before.
Doomsayers predicted that nobody would touch the game
that could be conquered by the machine,
and they were wrong, proven wrong,
but doomsaying has always been a popular pastime
when it comes to technology.
What I learned from my own experience
is that we must face our fears
if we want to get the most out of our technology,
and we must conquer those fears
if we want to get the best out of our humanity.
While licking my wounds,
I got a lot of inspiration
from my battles against Deep Blue.
As the old Russian saying goes, if you can't beat them, join them.
Then I thought,
what if I could play with a computer --
together with a computer at my side, combining our strengths,
human intuition plus machine's calculation,
human strategy, machine tactics,
human experience, machine's memory.
Could it be the perfect game ever played?
My idea came to life
in 1998 under the name of Advanced Chess
when I played this human-plus-machine competition against another elite player.
But in this first experiment,
we both failed to combine human and machine skills effectively.
Advanced Chess found its home on the internet,
and in 2005, a so-called freestyle chess tournament
produced a revelation.
A team of grandmasters and top machines participated,
but the winners were not grandmasters,
not a supercomputer.
The winners were a pair of amateur American chess players
operating three ordinary PCs at the same time.
Their skill of coaching their machines
effectively counteracted the superior chess knowledge
of their grandmaster opponents
and much greater computational power of others.
And I reached this formulation.
A weak human player plus a machine
plus a better process is superior
to a very powerful machine alone,
but more remarkably, is superior to a strong human player
plus machine
and an inferior process.
This convinced me that we would need
better interfaces to help us coach our machines
towards more useful intelligence.
Human plus machine isn't the future,
it's the present.
Everybody that's used online translation
to get the gist of a news article from a foreign newspaper,
knowing its far from perfect.
Then we use our human experience
to make sense out of that,
and then the machine learns from our corrections.
This model is spreading and investing in medical diagnosis, security analysis.
The machine crunches data,
calculates probabilities,
gets 80 percent of the way, 90 percent,
making it easier for analysis
and decision-making of the human party.
But you are not going to send your kids
to school in a self-driving car with 90 percent accuracy,
even with 99 percent.
So we need a leap forward
to add a few more crucial decimal places.
Twenty years after my match with Deep Blue,
second match,
this sensational "The Brain's Last Stand" headline
has become commonplace
as intelligent machines
move
in every sector, seemingly every day.
But unlike in the past,
when machines replaced
farm animals, manual labor,
now they are coming after people with college degrees
and political influence.
And as someone who fought machines and lost,
I am here to tell you this is excellent, excellent news.
Eventually, every profession
will have to feel these pressures
or else it will mean humanity has ceased to make progress.
We don't
get to choose
when and where technological progress stops.
We cannot
slow down.
In fact,
we have to speed up.
Our technology excels at removing
difficulties and uncertainties from our lives,
and so we must seek out
ever more difficult,
ever more uncertain challenges.
Machines have
calculations.
We have understanding.
Machines have instructions.
We have purpose.
Machines have
objectivity.
We have passion.
We should not worry about what our machines can do today.
Instead, we should worry about what they still cannot do today,
because we will need the help of the new, intelligent machines
to turn our grandest dreams into reality.
And if we fail,
if we fail, it's not because our machines are too intelligent,
or not intelligent enough.
If we fail, it's because we grew complacent
and limited our ambitions.
Our humanity is not defined by any skill,
like swinging a hammer or even playing chess.
There's one thing only a human can do.
That's dream.
So let us dream big.
Thank you.
(Applause)